غارة أمريكية دمرت
ساعات الليل في شمال غرب سوريا القوات الخاصة
التي تلاحق زعيم
تنظيم الدولة الإسلامية أبو إبراهيم الهاشم
الملقب حاج عبد الله الليلة الماضية ، والتي أدت
إلى إخراج زعيم إرهابي كبير من
ساحة المعركة وأرسلت رسالة قوية
إلى الإرهابيين في جميع أنحاء العالم.
تعال بعدك وتجد
الرئيس جو بايدن يشاهد من
البيت الأبيض بينما القوات الخاصة تقترب
من هدفها ، اقتربت المروحيات
من المجمع المكون من ثلاثة طوابق
في منتصف الليل وفقًا
لمسؤولين كبار بالإدارة مرة واحدة
على الأرض حذرت القوات الخاصة
المدنيين من ذلك.  إخلاء إجلاء 10
مدنيين بينهم ثمانية أطفال
يقول المسؤولون إن أكريشي ثم فجر نفسه
فقتل زوجته وأطفاله
وتمزيق الجزء العلوي من المبنى
، وقتل ملازمه في الطابق السفلي
في تبادل لإطلاق النار مع
القوات الأمريكية ، قال البنتاغون إن الطفل كان
أيضًا  قتل على هذا الطابق لكنه لم
يذكر كيف أو من قبل من في نهاية
العملية التي استغرقت ساعتين  ويقول مسؤولون إن اثنين
من أعضاء تنظيم القاعدة
قُتلا في تبادل لإطلاق النار مع
القوات الأمريكية ، كما اضطرت القوات الأمريكية إلى تدمير إحدى
طائرات الهليكوبتر على الأرض بعد
أعطال ميكانيكية ،
قُتل أربعة مدنيين إجمالًا وفقًا للبنتاغون
وخمسة مقاتلين.  لم تكن
الخطة وأقول أن إلقاء القبض على زعيم
داعش كان الهدف من المهمة هذه
الغارة كانت أكبر عملية
أمريكية في سوريا منذ عملية قتل أبو
بكر البغدادي في عام 2019 ،
الزعيم الأصلي لخلفية داعش
هناك بعض الغموض حول
مكان ولادته وتاريخ ميلاده غير الواضح أنه كان محتجزًا في الولايات المتحدة
في عام 2008 قبل
تسليمه إلى العراقيين ، وفي وقت ما
أطلق سراحه في مارس 2020 ،
صنفته وزارة الخارجية على أنه
إرهابي عالمي مُصنف خصيصًا مع 10
ملايين.  مكافأة بالدولار كان مسؤولاً
عن الهجوم الوحشي الأخير على سجن
في شمال شرق سوريا كان يحتجز مقاتلي تنظيم
الدولة الإسلامية.  ople في شمال
غرب العراق في عام 2014. القرشي لم
يغادر الطابق الثالث من المبنى في
شمال غرب سوريا باستثناء الاستحمام على
السطح ، قال مسؤولون في أوائل ديسمبر / كانون الأول إن
مسؤولي المخابرات يعتقدون أنهم
حددوا موقعه وأذن بايدن
بالعملية التي دعاها البيت الأبيض
موته ضربة لداعش ، لكن
التنظيم الإرهابي لا يزال يعاني
من هزيمة الخلافة المعلنة
في عام 2019 لديه خطط لإعادة البناء.